for a few days before my plane to Canada
was to take off my father confronted me
in the car one day and essentially asked
me to please not throw everything I ever
worked for away for something like this
now to be perfectly clear I do not
begrudge my father in the slightest for
asking me to do this I mean at the end
of the day he only wanted to do what was
best for me and he's trying to be a good
dad I mean he saw me making a massive
mistake and he was being honest with me
he wanted to be honest with me my issue
was I listened to him and I dropped
everything there and then after two
solid years of training in the gym and
in wrestling after all the travel and
the commitment that I had made to not
just myself but to other people I let it
go because I didn't want to disobey my
dad I didn't have the conviction to say
screw it and just go because I still
wish that I did even though it feels
kind of weird I mean I've I've had
success on YouTube and I'm very grateful
for that but
to this day it still bothers me